c'est l'un des endroits les plus
mythiques de la franche-comté sa
frontière avec la suisse 500 km2 ban ou
mont dolent et c est aujourd'hui très
agréable de s'y balader
c'était autrefois le lieu du trafic et
de la contrebande des hommes
transportaient sur eux
toutes sortes de marchandises et c'était
toute une vie parallèle qui s'organisait
pour échapper aux patrouilles des
douaniers thibault et laurent nous
raconte la petite histoire de l'art de
grandes contrebande et c'est passionnant
c'est là
[Musique]
le massif du jura se partage du nord au
sud entre deux pays la france et la
suisse pendant plusieurs siècles ces
montagnes plateaux des vallées furent
traversée par d'un solide personnage
appelé contrebandiers trafiquants prix
côtiers aux passeurs de lune ces hommes
et femmes faisait passer des
marchandises d'un pays à l'autre et qui
dit frontières dit douanes et contrôler
le passage de marchandises interdites
voulait dire prise de risque d'en face
au relief sinueuses et accidentées de
face au brigadier qui t'était et
patrouillaient notre parcours nous
emmènera entre goumois et villers le lac
où les gorges du doubs sauvage et
escarpée dessine une frontière naturelle
entre les deux pays
thibault est accompagnateur en montagne
il est l'auteur d'un livre qui raconte
la vie d'un contrebandier d'autrefois
avec lui nous remonterons les gorges à
contre-courant sur les traces de ces
mystérieux personnages qui hantent ses
paysages la frontière franco suisse
elle mesure un peu plus de 500 km de
long à aile par deux balles elle va
jusqu'au mont dolent dans le massif du
mont-blanc la frontière dans le paysage
ici elle s'appuie sur la rivière sur le
doubs et puis plus loin est le long de
la frontière franco-suisse elle va
s'appuyer sur des lignes de crête sur
des montagnes mais c'est bien les
éléments naturels qui vont organiser le
tracé de cette frontière montagnes
rivières et puis d'autres secteurs
également qu'ils sont va dire plus plat
alors ici depuis cette corniche on
domine le fameux village de goumois un
village franco suisse puisqu'il est
coupée en deux ma part la frontière par
le doubs un pont qui enjambe ce tracé
frontières en fait ils datent de 1780 et
ensuite il a été validé en 1814
mais je dirais l'identité surtout pour
moi c'est une identité franco suisse
avant tout
un village coupé en deux qui célèbre
plus volontiers la fête nationale suisse
le 1er août que le 14 juillet bonjour
laurent bonjour thibault alors vous qui
êtes douaniers ici aujourd'hui gardes
frontière suisses douaniers français
ça fait plusieurs décennies qu'il ya
plus de brigade neil de bureau côté
suisse il ya encore les
gardes-frontières mais pas en permanence
non plus surtout depuis qu'ils se sont
rentrés dans l'espace schengen ou 2008 à
cet endroit là la frontière était sur la
rive de l'autre côté ça veut dire que la
rivière est entièrement sur territoire
français et donc les contrôles douaniers
ne pouvait s'effectuer sur la rivière
que par les douanes françaises d'accord
donc quelqu'un qui par exemple trafic et
embarque ici seulement les douaniers
français selon la poubelle à cet endroit
la wii pourrait le contrôler qu'est ce
qui pouvait passer comme marchandises
comme trafic il y avait déjà des
marchandises déclarées depuis déjà le
19e siècle y avait des fournitures
d'horlogerie mais il y avait aussi du
trafic non déclaré de la clinique se
vendent ou ce qu'on appelle aussi de la
pacotille voir la bricole localement
alors là c'est des marchandises qui
étaient cachées sur les gens m'aiment
c'est pour ça que les contrôles étaient
importants des deux côtés de la
frontière parce que les les suisses
aussi soit on essaie en produits
alimentaires que des français je peux
vous montrer quelques cartes postales de
goumois volontiers voilà on voit le
public des pêcheurs et on voit surtout
ce qu'on appelle une aubette une petite
cabane qui était au prix du thon qui
permettait de préserver le douanier des
intempéries
c'est aux bêtes ont été abattues ou
presque n'en reste plus que deux sur la
frontière
les cartes postales des anciens postes
de douane que leur ans collectionne
témoignent d'un passé révolu
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de permanence
douanières dans ces gorges voile alors
on va traverser la frontière suisse
est ce que je vous propose c'est de
remonter le cours du doubs et puis de
vous emmener dans les gorges
[Musique]
alors ici laurent se trouve au te serais
est à l'image de cette meule tout le
long du linéaire du doubs on avait
différentes usines différentes
industries hautes sphères on avait à la
fois un moulin mais également une série
longue nous on retrouve deux usines
comme des clouteries détaillants andry
mais également par exemple des écrits
toutes ses différentes usines toute
cette industrie au fil de l'eau
évidemment utiliser la force hydraulique
alors il faut vous imaginer qu'à
l'époque dans la deuxième moitié du 19e
siècle
quand on aime on va dire au maximum de
la contrebande et bien le paysage ici
les gorges du doubs n'a rien à voir les
pans de chaque côté sont presque
totalement dépourvu de végétation et ça
principalement en raison des very parce
que c'est vers y exploitait énormément
le bois mais elles n'utilisaient pas la
force hydraulique
si bien qu'à un contrebandier qui
voulait descendre les gorges du doubs
traversée lourd remontée de l'autre côté
eh bien il était très exposée par
exemple à la vue des douaniers qui
pourrait le surveiller depuis les
hauteurs
il
[Musique]
aujourd'hui des peuples et est rendu à
la nature la vallée du doubs comptait
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle une
activité humaine conséquente avec ses
ateliers et usines le fond des gorges
était habité par cette communauté
d'artisans et d'ouvriers une vie sociale
en marge du travail agricole des
plateaux voisins
[Musique]
au hameau de biaufond les douaniers en
serait resté perplexe
c'est sur cette borne qui émerge au
milieu de l'eau que se rencontraient
jadis les trois évêchés celui de bâle de
lausanne et de besançon c'est ici que la
ligne frontière qui t'arrive suisse à
présent la rivière se partageant son
milieu entre les deux pays
[Musique]
laurent alors ici on arrive au célèbre
pavillon du sonar alors cet endroit sa
particularité c'est que jusqu'en 1880 la
date de construction du pont biaufond et
bien entre morteau égouts moi il n'y
avait aucun pont pour pouvoir traverser
le doubs c'est bien que les habitants
que les français comme côté suisse était
obligé de venir ici alors le sonar
évidemment faisait sonner une cloche et
ensuite il faisait traverser les gens
sur une barque
voilà en tout cas un lieu de passage qui
a fonctionné comme ça pendant très
longtemps le pêcheur qui est également
passeur faisait office de douaniers
permettait donc de traverser sur la rive
française qui a été le quotidien des
douaniers comment ils exerçaient leur
patrouille ils douaniers français il
avait une zone d'action qu'on appelait
la pente hier la pente hier c'est en
gros un petit territoire de quelques
kilomètres carrés qui était divisé en
plusieurs secteurs qui patrouillaient
dans un sens dans l'autre il avait des
points de contrôle qu'on appelle aussi
les point d'apparition et c'est là qu'il
ait essayé de piéger des contrebandiers
en montant des embuscades
donc il dessinait des cartes à la main
avec des noms de lieux dits très précis
les cartes et terre jusqu'au 1 10
millièmes et il indiquait la toux les
bonnes apparitions
c'est une carte qui était affiché sur
les murs de leur noyade qui remettait à
jour régulièrement
donc j'avais des endroits où ils
allaient se cacher il aller planquer des
endroits précis les utiliser leur
bagnole c'est le terme pour le lead
embuscade et il pourrait rester toute
une nuit a tenté d'intercepter une bande
de contrebandiers et donc en fait les
douaniers faisait preuve d'astuce pour
comme les contrebandiers par exemple on
pouvait être des sabots inversé on était
un peu déçu qu'à l'époque on mettait le
talon la passe de la pointe du talent on
inversait on pouvait aussi évident et
des roues de calèche évident et des
rondins de bois quand on allait à la
fois utiliser des patins à glace sur ce
que le 12e l'est quand on utilisait
aussi des trucs astuces qui était
adaptée aux particularités du terrain
[Musique]
en
cette fois c'est sur la rive française
que nous retrouvons thibault qu'ils
abordent à présent le site des échelles
de la mort a lieu mythique bar bien des
aspects
[Musique]
e
elle départ de la via ferrata nous on va
prendre les échelles de la mort c'est
quand même beaucoup plus tranquille à
l'époque c'était les travailleurs des
moulins du fond des gorges qui
empruntait le chemin le plus court pour
rejoindre le plateau il utilisait les
couleurs ses passages en creux des
falaises où il fallait parfois fixés une
échelle pour accéder plus haut les
premières traces d'un passage aménagé
remonte au 15e siècle les échelles
n'était alors que des troncs d'arbres
coupés posé à même la falaise
ce n'est qu'au début du xxème siècle que
l'acier a remplacé le bois
[Musique]
art à l'origine les échelles de la mort
s'imaginer que c'était juste une
personne en bois traversé par des
barreaux les échelles de la mort 1 le
nom fait peur globalement mais en fait
c'est lié cet endroit là des gorges du
doubs qui est très encaissés on
l'appelle la vallée de la mort on n'a
également pas très loin sur la rive cuif
l'éguille de la mort on avait le moulin
de la mort on pense aussi certainement
que les contrebandiers avait donné ce
nom là afin que les gens ne viennent pas
trop dans le coin est également les
douaniers c'est à dire de vraiment faire
un peu peur aux gens ici on a un symbole
de la contrebande
c'est notre dame de la briquette la
briquette c'était la contrebande de
monsieur et madame tout le monde
brico tout pacotille c est les
marchandises de première nécessité alors
on mettait des îles vierges un peu
partout comme ça dans les gorges du
doubs en direction de la suisse en
protection pour les contrebandiers mais
elle regarde toujours en direction de la
rive-sud aujourd'hui à défaut de
protéger les contrebandiers elle protège
les randonneurs
[Musique]
quand on vit rennes via ferrata déjà on
vient pour le cadre le cadre naturel et
puis pour cet esprit nature grimper au
rocher en toute facilité se dire on peut
prendre de la hauteur
sans forcément ressembler aux grands
champions des escalades et la magnifique
des barreaux des échelles on progresse
en toute sécurité
et on va rechercher un petit peu
d'adrénaline puisque là on a quand même
pratiquement 80 voire 100 mètres de vide
et ça c'est pas donné à tous de pouvoir
s'accrocher comme ça la falaise tu as
ton matériel tu viens tu es tranquille
tu l'as fait voilà il n'y a pas de
redevance est un petit peu comme tout et
via ferrata en france est bon on n'a pas
assez tard et ici on a quand même une
des plus belles via ferrata de france
super aérienne
un cadre magnifique ça on peut pas
l'enlever aux contrebandiers sais pas si
vous avez le temps de voir à l'époque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
françois habite le plateau et arpentent
les sentiers du doubs depuis son enfance
ses paysages transfrontalier non plus
beaucoup de secrets pour lui sur la
crête au dessus des échelles c'est avec
lui que thibaut poursuit sanctionnant
une image très romanesque de la
contrebande
il faudrait se remettre dans le contexte
de l'époque et quand même avec à la fois
les grands prédateurs qui sont présents
le loup lynx même lourd ce qui est
présent puisque les derniers n'ont pas
été tués ya si longtemps que ça pèse et
puis faut mettre les brigadiers qui sont
là aussi ancien guerrier entre un ancien
militaire qui va dans les côtes du doubs
le doubs lui même qui n'est pas régulé
par ibra g puis qu'il faut à ces sautes
d'humeur quand on arrive pour traverser
votre foyer il ya les grosses crues ne
pas traverser ou si nous traversons
seraient coincés et puis après que deux
se retrouvent dans des difficultés comme
les falaises où il faut passer avec les
échelles avec tout ça on a encore un
obstacle de plus impressionnant alors
les gars vont circuler pour la les deux
jours généralement parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de raison qu'ils se fassent arrêtées
dont ils vont passer tranquillement la
canne à pêche sur l'épaule il passe les
d'où la difficulté ça va être heureux
tout est là le retour de faire le plus
vite possible
donc c'est là quelques fois une nuit
entière avec des arrêts souvent des
arrêts dans dix villes faible on a
l'exemple au dessus de dieu d'amour la
vieille ferme de chez france où on sait
que ça faisait bistrot comme toutes les
fermes et dans l'écurie avait une double
paroi
les contrebandiers en traits d'un côté
posaient les ballots ressortait aller
s'installer à table
et quand éloigné arrivée dans le bistrot
bas il ya une équipe de là en train de
jouer aux cartes tranquillement n'y
avait pas franchement de l'as poser de
questions c'était contrebandiers ou pas
il faut bien penser qu un ballot de 40
kg de tabac sur le dos c'est pas si
facile que ça à manipuler surtout qu'ils
avaient pas nos sacs à dos les ballots
tout simple en toile attaché plus ou
moins bien avec le système pour le
décrocher plus vite possible au cas en
cas d' attaque est la plus plan de
lancer dgac ont l'habitude de cette
année c'est des braconniers c'est des
gens qui ont déjà essayé de contourner
la loi et puis qui savent s'échapper
très vite se cacher se camoufler
utiliser le terrain et donc ils ont
l'habitude de passer ses frontières
assez facilement
vous imaginez qu'un moustique laval
n'était pas tout à fait comme ça il y
avait certainement moins de couverture
d'art puisqu'on avait cette époque des
verreries c'est l'époque des
charbonniers donc des grandes ouvertures
dont difficile c'est se cacher des
hommes à ne pas se cacher fallait passer
là au milieu alors que les suisses ont
réagi très vite quand ils ont vu qu'il y
avait de la recherche de marchandises
les gens sont venus depuis les villes
s'installer le long du doubs dans les
petites auberges qu'on trouve tout le
long et puis là-bas les points de vente
c'était vraiment les petites épiceries
qui approvisionnait les contrebandiers
pour l'abricot tu déjà lu mais est le
tabac la poutre et jeux de cartes qui
était axé tout ce qui était taxée va
passer la frontière comme ça par contre
les plus grosses bandes de
contrebandiers qui me fout la grosse
marchandises qui passent dans les
ballots de tabac et dont l'influencé
forte en france puisqu'on la retrouve
jusqu'à dijon un mot donner le roi de
france commence à avoir peur et ils vont
alors de contacter des villas cc
neuchâtel c'est la chaux-de-fonds ils
vont chercher plus loin leur marchandise
pour gagner de l'argent mais on sait que
j'aimerais contrebande et qui a fini
très riche
[Musique]
à
ce conte un peu plus d'informations à
montsûrs d'où venaient ces douaniers les
premiers douaniers c'est le roi de
france qui quand il s'aperçoit que la
contrebande efforts tu vas emprisonnés
ces contrebandiers et puis il leur donne
un choix dans dix ans c'est sur les
galères ça vous offrir les douanes donc
on sait que les premiers douaniers vont
être des contrebandiers repenti quelque
part qui s'ils sont efficaces parce
qu'ils connaissent les astuces et qui
vont être déplacés de région bien sûr
pourront apprécier de mèches la
population dans ta famille tu vois ça
trafic est un peu mes parents ont fait
d'abricotiers souvenu mme armand on
partait à la chaux-de-fonds
et puis elle allait s'acheter des débats
et elle se mettait trois quatre paires
de bas les unes sur les autres
elle transpirait la pauvre mme une
malheureuse et puis vous passez la
frontière comme ça quoi et voilà c'était
une contrebande petit mais efficace pour
la maison et nous souvient d'être passé
la douane avec des gaufrettes ont passé
découvre et en contrebas parle pas des
camions et puis on mangeait ces gouffres
et à la maison vous semblez vous spécial
passer la douane le goût de l'illégalité
s'ouvre la soul
dans les années 50 la construction du
barrage hydroélectrique dans la vallée
fait disparaître sous les eaux la trace
d'anciens moulins et forges et avec elle
le souvenir d'une époque
un peu plus en amont le saut du doubs a
gardé son panache en frontignes bouffée
de fraîcheur au vendeur
[Musique]
thibault qu'on est ici un personnage qui
n'a pas oublié la vie d'avant si rené
qu'elle est si bien la vie des gorges
c'est qu'il est né ici
il conserve précieusement dans sa
boutique des documents sur la validante
et voilà où je n'ai la maison ici sur la
barque
c'est quand j'avais à peu près 17 ans je
faisais la traversée des gens france en
suisse suisse en france
d'accord il acheter leur tabac leur
cigarette temps en temps il y avait un
douanier qui les attendait c'était pas
ça voilà je me faisais pas tant qu'auto
bornes alors qu'ici dans les gorges du
doubs il ya eu des personnages célèbres
homo couleurs le fameux némorin qu'heidi
némorin des lots douala c'est ça un pur
produit du braconnage locale donc il a
passé sa vie à à pêcher enfin chasser la
loutre braconné y vivait comme ça de
pêche de chasse ça payait bien les
poules outre il ya ce monsieur là qu'on
a peine l'amiral était un personnage qui
transportait les gens des brenets au
saut du loup et temps en temps à citer
ce ratio est un petit peu par exemple
les sacs de grenouilles qui mettait dans
les bacs donc ça partait dans les
restaurants côté france
dargaud
le saut du doubs et c'est rapide
impétueux ont laissé la place aux
bassins silencieux de la rivière
divers
lorsque l'eau gelait les bassins se
transformer un dimanche patinoire
dans les méandres les contrebandiers en
profitait pour chausser leurs patins à
glace et traverser rapidement la rivière
d'une rive à l'autre
c'est à villers-le-lac que la frontière
quitte les eaux du tout pour rejoindre
la terre et s'accrocher au relief le col
des roches marque la limite des
territoires
[Musique]
de nos jours la vanille au rythme du
bail bien des travailleurs frontaliers
qui seront en suisse de goumois à
billère bénac ce sont plus de six mille
véhicules par jour qui sillonnent les
routes franco helvétique
même si la frontière se déplace
aujourd'hui vers les centres de tri
postaux ou les plateformes de fret
il subsiste encore quelques points de
passage sous la vigilance de nyer comme
ici au col des roches la frontière
franco-suisse celui des dernières
frontières gérer douanière mans entre
guillemets un peu à l'ancienne c'est à
dire que avant 93 on avait des
frontières qui était douanier rement
marqué avec tous nos voisins européens
aujourd'hui on ne voit plus des passeurs
transporter des marchandises comme ça
prohibée à dos d'hommes à travers la
forêt alors ici l'expression s'est passé
sous les sapins
quand on veut éviter le douanier on
évite justement de passer par par les
points de passage qui sont gardés ou
dont on sait que les douaniers vont
surveiller et donc on appelle ça passait
sous les sapins
à une époque on avait la contrebande par
exemple sur le sel défaut saunier petits
trafics et le sel pour pas payé à
l'époque la gabelle c'est pour ça que
les douaniers sont souvent surnommés les
gabelous stupéfiants contrefaçon les
douaniers sont aussi à l'affût des
évadés fiscaux qui rapatrie
clandestinement en argent liquide leurs
capitaux en france au fil de l'histoire
on a un peu une course en matière de
techniques de dissimulation
on va vers les techniques qui sont
toujours de plus en plus élaborées alors
il ya ce qu'on appelle le faire du
douanier c'est à dire que l'exercent son
travail au quotidien avec tout son vécu
avec toute l'expérience accumulée ce
qu'il a déjà vu ou pas vu une situation
nouvelle va parfois attiré éveiller ses
soupçons
la qualité essentielle passé d'être
curieux c'est d'avoir un peu cette âme
de chasseurs parce que sa demande ait
des qualités d'observation une patience
toute particulière que quelquefois on
revient bredouille il faut accepter de
revenir bredouille retour de l'émission
[Musique]
notre parcours à saute frontières nous
entraîne sur les hauteurs du même usine
le depor ne tracent le chemin
[Musique]
depuis le col des roches la frontière
suit la ligne de crête du même musique
on est ici sur un chemin de douaniers à
droite du mur et c'est la france
à gauche c'est la suisse
touche minla dans l'ombre c'est le mardi
contrebandiers à la barbe du douanier
licence en brune dans la nuit sombre
comme un fantôme à nos services regardez
le rien ne l'arrête miraval galtier ni
l'ombre effaçant les sentiers il faudra
brodant sur sa tête
un gouffre béant sous ses pieds il faut
t'il d'un bon intrépide franchir
précipice ou faux c'est quand par la
meute il est pressé le chevreuil n'est
pas plus rapide
le renard n'est pas plus rose et on peut
parler d'une tradition mais d'une
tradition qui s'est perdue notamment
autour de ses poésies de ses chansons un
des personnages on va dire qui à forger
le mythe du contrebandier c'est le
personnage de mandrin donc mandera en au
xviiie siècle et il va défier la
monarchie française à travers les
fermiers généraux et il va avec ses
bandes en fait trafic et entre la savoie
à la france
et le canton de genève principalement le
contrebandier comme étant une sorte de
robin des bois celui qui va prendre aux
riches pour donner aux pauvres
voilà va commencer à vraiment à germer
dans la population et puis il va être
mandrin extrêmement populaire long du
xixème siècle la culture populaire
s'appuyer sur différentes choses par
exemple je pense aux jeux douaniers et
contrebandiers aïssi dans le haut doubs
les enfants et je veux pas aux cow-boys
et aux indiens
et puis on a des citations des dictons
parfois un peu à la gloire de la
contrebande ou au contraire qu'ils nous
font nous méfier des risques encourus
par les contrebandiers exemple d'un
dicton populaire qui disait contrebande
n'a qu'une saison
aujourd'hui riol à foison mené riol en
patois franc comtois savoir à grand
train de vie
demain le mari en prison et la misère à
la maison donc là c'était l'objectif
c'était justement un peu dissuader de
faire de la contrebande
on a également une fête de
contrebandiers puisque le le patron des
contrebandiers c'est saint michel et
tous les 29 septembre les contrebandiers
par exemple aux rousses faisait à grande
gueule ton à côté si possible du poste
de douane pour provoquer les douaniers
voilà un exemple de ce qu'est la culture
on va dire de la contrebande
dans le haut doubs mais également dans
le haut jura j'arrête tout le long de
cette frontière franco suisse
une terre de passage où tout circule les
marchandises mais aussi les hommes des
idées une limite de territoire qui
sépare et rapproche à la fois la
frontière se poursuit plus au sud par de
la montagne des vallées emportant avec
elle d'autres histoires de
contrebandiers les lois ne sont qu'une
barrière veine que les hommes francis
tous par dessus les grands pas sans
peine les petits partis
ça donne parfois des frissons n'est ce
pas mais enfin allez-y sans crainte
aujourd'hui je vous conseille d'ailleurs
là bien ferrata de stéphane et les
splendides a laissé là c'est terminé
pour aujourd'hui je vous embrasse
surtout prenez soin de vous d'ici à la
semaine prochaine
je vous embrasse
[Musique]